hello
i'm paul cowling with film independent
and welcome to
coffee talks today we have something a
little different
uh seeing as we are in the middle of
awards season we thought it would be
great to
assemble a group of film and media
tv critics to talk shop talk about their
business their work and their writings
and seeing as it's also black history
month why not make it a roundtable of
black film critics
so i'm going to do my intros uh
alphabetically
and then step off stage and hand over to
our group so
first up she's a freelance tv and film
journalist she contributes to the new
york times uh
l and huffington post uh candice
frederick
is here with us hey candice wanna turn
on your step on stage
how you doing i'm well how are you glad
to be here
very well thank you thanks for joining
us where are you
i am in brooklyn new york okay
yeah we're after lunch for you thanks
for joining us
towards the end of the day yeah yeah
it's great to have you with us
uh next up uh he's the editor-in-chief
of
lenoiroter.net that's the website too
lenoir-alter.net
and a member of the hollywood critics
association and someone i know quite
well
terence johnson is here hey terrence
step up on stage how are you doing hi
i'm doing good how about you very well
thanks you're in your um
man cave your little i'm in my i'm in my
like den my living room den here in los
angeles
thanks for joining us i'll be scanning
the shelves while you speak here
i recognize anything there next up he's
the managing editor for
we live entertainment he's contributed
to variety and
co-host of the podcast out now with
aaron and abe
erin newerth is with us hey aaron hello
hi how you doing i'm doing well how are
you
i already heard that but i asked anyway
because i want to know also
uh also in your movie den right
yes lots of goodies there behind you
um yeah you got a lot of um blu-ray and
dvd envy from people in the audience i'm
sure
so now 4k envy as well i guess
wow where are you joining us from i am
down in orange county california
great uh we uh and then
i'll finally do our moderator here
he is the um none other than the
co-founder and president of the
african-american film critics
association
uh he's written for the la times fortune
magazine
and the atlanta journal constitution
among
many others uh gil robertson is with us
hey girl
hey paul how you doing very well thank
you how are you
i'm good where are you i'm in i'm in
marietta georgia
right now okay so um
we may have a surprise guest joining us
later but for now
i'm gonna step off stage and let the
four of you
start chatting and uh
i'll be back to wrap it up at the very
end so
take it away gil great great great
hi everybody happy thursday
happy thursday thursday it's happy
thursday
we're almost there we're almost there
you know
so and we're almost at the end of black
history month so um
yeah hopefully it was a good month for
everybody
it was short as usual
yeah it was good it was busy good yes it
has been
so you know let's talk about uh each of
your your pathways
to success to your present you know
situation uh as journalists um candace
why don't we start off with you
um what was your inspiration
and what type of preparation that you
initially take in terms of
was there any kind of formal training or
was just simply something that you've
always
you've just learned had a natural gift
for
i went to school for journalism so i
have a degree in journalism
and from there i've kind of been in
media almost exclusively since then
um i uh my second professional job
after getting a degree was um
at essence that was where i got my
professional start as a journalist
i was there for a couple years and
i was primarily writing and editing
arts lifestyle books related stories
and it's a women's lifestyle magazine so
there was a lot of
content that was catered specifically
for black women
so from there i um i think
i mean i left there and i uh kind of
took a completely different path but i
started like blogging
um and that kind of uh as i was doing
that as i was
having i had many uh day jobs
while i was blogging and i started
blogging about
uh film and tv particularly because um
that was just something i was doing a
lot of at the time and i already had the
journalism background
and so i just kind of it was just it was
supposed to be something i was just
doing
in in between jobs
but it turned out i'm still doing it
like 15 years later
but but um yeah i i'm
full-time freelance right now i'm
writing for a variety of
publications um and so yeah i do
everything from like reported pieces
profiles
um reviews so it runs the gamut
you're writing for some of the biggest
magazines on this planet so you're doing
quite well my friend
thank you uh aaron what about you let's
talk about your path
uh so it comes basically just from a
passion for
film and having the opportunity to find
a way to
present that early on uh before i was
professionally writing by any means i
was
just kind of like blogging on this site
flixster that i think since become
rotten tomatoes and all that um
but during that time and that's like
2006
i think uh but eventually i got over to
got over to comic con one year where i
met
uh another writer brian white who owns
the site why so blue.com
and because i'm the person that likes to
talk to people we were sitting in a
panel together
and uh he told me about the site he was
working like he was editing it
in his chair i told him how i was just i
enjoy writing about movies right happy
so he gave me a shot at
you know starting to publish reviews on
an actual website as opposed to on a
random
movie blog page um around that same time
i'd start my own blog
and combine between that and why so blue
i just started writing
on a more frequently frequent basis and
that
from there just kind of built up as far
as getting to know
certain people to get press contacts uh
to get pr contacts which led me to
getting
actual like screenings to attend um
going along that path just kind of you
know putting in the putting in the hours
essentially to
write more and more reviews which led me
to meet more people uh during the time i
also started the podcast i hosted my
friend abe called out mouth
so we talk about weekly movie releases
there and because i meet a lot of
various journalists what have you at
screenings i you know have guests on
all the time with that so just it's a
lot of you know just learning
and meeting more and more people getting
more and more context and
that led me to eventually to wheel of
entertainment where i started writing
there for scott menzel
the editor man creator of that site and
yeah it's just opened up a lot of
continued opportunities so i've
since moved on as mentioned i've been
contributing a couple times to variety
at this point
um
i mean yeah it's it's not a full-time
job it is
just a for me it's like i i have the i
can do this thing
and i get a modicum amount of
supplemental income from that but it's
still something i just
really enjoy doing and i'm very happy to
have various outlets that are larger and
larger
that i can contribute to and it's your
passion
it's your passion project very much so
well that's great
that's great and terence what about you
um i definitely feel like i have the
most roundabout way
of getting to where i am um i
started blogging um when i was in
undergrad where i was getting a degree
in civil engineering
at georgia tech because i was in atlanta
and at the time that was right when
production started to move to atlanta
so you had your vampire diaries your
teen wolves and your walking dead
were shot there um and so i started
getting interested in film and i had
friends who were interested in film and
we'd go to
atlantic station and they'd be like hey
you like movies why don't you write
about them
and so i created my first blog called
the tomas experience
uh tomas was my spanish nickname in high
school
um and based off of nathaniel rogers who
runs the film experience
i sort of used him as a template but
then you know i went out into the
working world with
the field of my degree was in um
and i noticed there was a website award
circuit run by clayton davis who's now
at variety
um and he was looking for people to
write news and i was like well i sit at
a computer
all day and i want to write about film
maybe i can do this
as well um and so that's sort of how i
got my start and i started off
just being like hey this new trailer
came out
here's a bit about the trailer and then
that moved into
covering film festivals and covering
comic-con
um and then eventually moving out here
to come and do film school
um and around that time i started
transitioning my blog to a much more
professional
it's like a mix between a blog and a
site um
and yeah i've just been doing that sort
of ever since
and like aaron this is like a part it's
a full-time
hobby but like not my full-time job
um so but it's just been great to be
able to get to
go to screenings and and meet people and
cover
these festivals um and get to talk about
uh film and tv which i'm passionate
about
great great yeah doing it full time is
uh is not easy i i spent the majority of
my career
uh when i was actively writing uh
freelancing and it's
it takes uh yes
yes basically yeah
candace let's talk about that though how
you've been able to successfully though
put the pieces together and really
create a sustainable
uh life for yourself as a freelance uh a
any
journalist and film critic it's not easy
uh and i i get that question a lot and
my short answer is i don't know
um i do i am candles and
candles and saying a little prayer about
it i i
will say that i have a lot of drive i
have my ear on the
on the ground a lot um i'm a hustler by
nature
i think i'm originally from boston i've
been living in new york for about
um probably about 21 years now
um and so once i got here
i just i just hit the ground i just
started that was kind of how i
approached every job i had
and when i became a professional
journalist and
um when i started
going more into the film and tv route of
film
of journalism i just absorbed everything
that i could i read everything that i
could in terms of like articles in terms
of like
um having relationships with publicists
which is extremely critical
um and also equally critical
is relationships with editors um and
yeah uh and also social media is a
gigantic tool
that i use for networking my work
my voice as a writer um and so i think
that in just the way since i'm doing
this full time now as a freelancer
um financially that just takes a lot of
like balancing for me
and like i have to do things in a
certain way in order to
make first of the month rent so and so a
lot of that is just like
by trial and error a lot of it came by
just experience and doing it for
this long um but yeah it's not
easy and it takes it takes a lot more
than passion it takes a lot of
discipline and a lot of just like
saying no you know um negotiating up
i cannot say i cannot stress that enough
um so things like that
uh yeah we just got our first question
but i'll get to that later uh jonathan
before we wrap things up
uh let's talk about um
creating a profile for yourself because
you know as
candace was just saying you know
establishing yourself
uh in earning developing a reputation
you know within the industry means uh
getting to know um and
studio execs and managers and etc etc so
that
you have access to the talent that
you're looking to
uh to write about so what's been your
uh hurdle what's been you what's been
your um
your um how have you managed to
overcome uh those hurdles
of getting to know and really getting to
establish a profile for yourself
why don't we start with terrance uh yeah
one
thing that i think is important
like that candace and aaron sort of hit
on of like talking to people or being in
with the publicist
the thing that sort of really like
launched me
at award circuit um was that
i was covering film scores like i did a
thing every award season that was like
spotlight on scores where i would talk
about
because i love film music um and i just
talk about oh like this is the score
this is why i loved it this is why it
may or may not be nominated for an oscar
and that started getting the attention
of the publicist of the people that
handle
those composers because that's not
necessarily a field
that everybody is angling to cover and
so when they see it they're like oh hey
like i have this client would you be
interested in
interviewing him or like hey like you
know we
i meet them at a convention and we talk
and it'd be like a wonderful
conversation and i just sort of used
that
as like a jumping off point like i
really think you have to find
my one one of the few pieces of advice
that i i have today is just like finding
because there are so many people talking
about movies now it's a little different
than when all of us started
um you know just especially online like
when i got into starting writing online
it was like
everybody was starting to write online
and now everybody really is writing
online
so it's really about finding the things
that
you don't see other people working on
but that you're also passionate about
that's what really helped me
in the beginning and i was a big you
know as you can see by the various
toys and things behind me um very into
the pop culture
um things and so i would go to comic con
i would just
and that made me invaluable to clayton
because i was the only one going
you know so i got all of the comics
related people all of the
you know the tv and the movie people
that were going there i got to talk to
and cultivate those relationships with
so it really is about like
figuring out the stuff that you like to
write about that you maybe don't see
already in the in the marketplace so
finding your niche finding your language
within
yeah canvas
those building blocks uh you know
establishing the relationship
uh with the uh the publicist with the
people that you need to know
in order to uh you know fortify your
brand
yeah i mean i
i i i say more voice than brand
uh only because i don't really have
a niche in terms of what type of films
that i cover or tv
um and so i don't really like to i don't
really like the idea of being
pigeonholed but i do think that as a
black person particularly as a black
woman
i am often pigeonholed but that's not
something that i put on myself
just because i know that that's already
going to be something that's going to be
put on me and that's a constant hurdle
between uh on both the editor and as
well as the public
publicist end and so that is something
that i think is
is still a struggle i mean i think
people who are
who are just starting out have more of a
struggle with that
um but i mean i've been doing it for a
while so it's not
as much it's not it doesn't present
itself as much
like oh i can only cover xyz just
because i'm a black woman
um uh and so that was something that i
was running into
a lot early on so that's the next
question actually
oh really i'll stop talking then
no no no no no um and
aaron um
same question yeah yes
i um you know for for me as far as like
hurdles
that i've had to overcome i mean in
terms of like developing
who i am as the writer i want to be or
like what i want to put out there
yeah it's not the way i've been viewing
this it hasn't been a matter of i want
to you know be a part of this
by way of this thing like i haven't
tried to define myself by a certain
thing i do there's
there's things i lean into if i want to
continually randomly posting about
godzilla i'm going to do it because i
like godzilla but i mean it's not
the area where i'm like this is the only
thing i'm going to cover so as far as
hurdles go it's been a matter of
just being on a constant you know being
on that constant level with various
publicists or what have you just to have
the access
that i require um to do the thing that i
want to do
as opposed to you know having to like
really search around for it
the overcoming that hurdle is just again
putting in that
putting in that time and effort and
regardless of how deep a relationship
goes with anybody that you're contacting
with on emails is just
having the having the you know the
ability to reach out to the right people
and you know find what you need as far
as screening access or interview access
or what have you and that's
you know i don't know what the correct
answer is as far as how to tell you know
people that are newer to this
arena like how to do that but it i mean
experience and putting in the time is
certainly a major factor
well one thing would be consistency i
mean to certainly if you
you know have an assignment if you uh
you know
uh if you have an assignment a you
deliver it and deliver it on time
and if you and recognizing that people's
time
uh is money you know that's how i look
at it so if you're
interviewing someone of your you know
going to see a movie that
there's certain expectation that comes
with with those
outings you know and i think that's a
big way
that people are able to you know
establish a name
uh for their for their work uh for their
bylines that enable them to
uh get the access that they need in
order to grow their careers
but let's just real quick i just i like
it you know
the the goal for me is just make it easy
like
the i feel like we can all like we all
like writing i think that's a big part
of it and i
i certainly am passionate about the
writing process and you know
the easier it is to get to do the thing
you need to do to get to that point
where you can write about it
the better it's really helpful to like
you know have a certain kind of rapport
or to have all the right contacts in the
world but like bottom line is
if it's easy to get done it's easy to
get that access then great that's that's
what i'm looking for
if they're you know what the results i
get out of that as far as building a
bigger base building a bigger audience a
bigger viewership
that's that's gravy essentially but the
goal i have in mind is just like i want
to be able to put my voice out there
which is like
good i could that could be right another
thing i'm saying is you only got to get
the access as if you're consistent in
your delivery
yeah let's talk about race and talk
about
uh what role it's played in
in your career uh has it had uh has it
had
impact or is it something that you that
you know i mean i know that uh
you terrence you are in particular you
specialize in a particular genre largely
so maybe maybe race hasn't been as much
of a factor for you as it might be for
candace or for aaron who
may write about right a broad set of
things
yeah i think i lucked initially i think
i left into
writing for a word circuit because
clayton is a person of color
um so it never
it never had to be a situation where
like i am the black male
writer on the staff who likes
genre stuff like i like lots of things
like if i
you know if you want me to review the
three hour oscar contender i will do it
um you know but like
sort of having that sort of protection
from your your editor in chief was
was great but then sort of as i've gone
on
it's i only feel like it comes like with
me
just i only feel like it it comes up
when there's like an expectation on a
movie whether or not a black person is
supposed to like it or not
and that doesn't necessarily have to be
strictly black content i think about
something like the revenant
which i did not like and i still do not
like to this day
but like a lot of the blowback
from stuff like that can be like oh like
you're black you don't get a movie like
that
you know conversely it's like if you
don't like a black movie and you're
reviewing it
it's like oh but like we need it to
succeed because it's black and so though
that's where i find sort of
you know the really difficult line to
walk with regards to race
and you know you get you know people
comment
on things and they have you know they
feel like they could say whatever to you
because you'll never see them face to
face um
but like yeah for me it's more about
like what the expectations
are on this movie that you then come in
within a review that you either meet or
you don't
um so that's sort of where it's been
sort of the most
there's like a really famous moment
where i
said zac efron gave like a decent
performance in in the south by southwest
movie
uh and somebody came at me with a pretty
funny comment um
but like outside of that it hasn't it
hasn't quite played
um a role but i i think it has
been tough with regards to access like
aaron is talking about i'm sure candace
knows it's like
like when they have the black movie you
get all the access that you need
but when it's not the movie with all the
black people in it
then it's like maybe you get the last
screening
or you don't and that is hard when
you're trying to make a name for
yourself
and you need to review the movie around
the same time everybody else is to be in
that conversation
that goes both ways though right yeah i
mean like thinking i think of something
like
the black panther release where in la
disney was very happy to announce how
they shipped in
many black critics from across the
country and i know huo didn't get to go
to that premiere
um
you know and yes there's an
understanding that
not everyone is writing on the same
level exactly but at the same time it's
like well
where are those and that's not just
speaking exclusively to us on this
you know this broadcast but there are
you know there are plenty of people of
color and specifically black critics of
the world like
what is what is the requirement to be in
this special panel of like we get pulled
to be in this you know
premiere for this giant black
blockbuster i don't know what that is
exactly
i know what you're saying as far as yeah
there are certain movies that have
exclusively black cats or certainly
focused in that arena
that for whatever reason you suddenly oh
there's all this access we have to it
but when it comes to some of these
bigger players
not not quite not always the same uh and
i don't have an answer to that but it's
certainly something you can notice when
you're
seeing on twitter a live stream of all
of these people that are at this
premiere and it's like oh that's nice
so i mean aaron how have you navigated
grace uh manage that
uh with in dealing with your editors and
dealing with some of the
other people that you uh have to deal
with to uh get your stories
you know i can't say that there's like
been a direct
incident or anything of that nature
that's like affected me as far as what
i'm doing now i can't say that that's
not that's impossible that didn't happen
because
that's just the nature of the world i i
am a
a mixed-race black critic that works in
this world and
no doubt has faced certain things
whether i'm aware of them or not
um but as far as how it's affected me
i'm you know i don't try to let things
get me down i want to do a thing and i'm
going to you know work the best way i
can
are there certain angles you can work to
accomplish that perhaps
are there ways to you know make your
voice heard or express a certain kind of
opinion
yes there are and you can do that
through social media means or just in
emails or what have you
i haven't had to you know confront
anybody over a way that i felt
disrespected or whatnot i feel
lucky for that i know others are less
fortunate in that matter but i've
started you know
just like this black panther thing i
pointed out which is not something i'm
holding over anyways just an example but
it's the kind of thing where you kind of
notice it where
where i feel where you know not
necessarily like a benefit but where i
feel i've
tried to kind of do something in that
regard
it's out honestly having the podcast i
host the podcast my friend abe who is of
asian descent
and we have a variety of guests on every
week including terrance a number of
times
that are of a broad spectrum that
doesn't mean i dis-include
certain people but it's it's nice to
think
you know someone on a level that i am
which is not super high in
all you know respective things along
with my friend who doesn't have any you
know kind of critical
uh background we're just happy to get on
and talk about movies together and have
other critics on that similarly
for the most part don't have the largest
voice in the community there's you know
there's some
notable guests or what have you that i
could you know that we've had on but
a lot of it's just people that we get
that relate to us that are also
generally there's a lot of people of
color what have you and i
you know whatever i can't accomplish on
the base that i'm at as far as my
writing goes i'm happy to think that
you know a podcast that i've been doing
for nearly a decade now that's something
i can contribute as far as getting
other voices out there i mean do you
feel a responsibility like
terence was mentioning it mentioning and
i know canvas has had to deal with this
as as
have i to black content
oh do you have a responsibility to it do
you feel a response
yeah do i feel a responsibility to it
it's
to a degree as far as
there are certain kinds of films that
just won't get that much attention and
i'm not you know now that's not
specifically not talking about you know
the big blockbusters are big you know
mainstream films but other ones where
yeah they're made by people of color
that are from smaller studios or what
have you and
there's going to be plenty of reviews
written about the big movies there's not
going to be as many reviews
about the smaller movies that have these
other voices what they're established or
not
and especially now in this quarantine
we've been living in
where there are a lot of movies out
there specifically not mainstream ones
but that are just streaming and that is
going out there and have no press or
without you
i i do like that i have a chance on a
weekly basis to write about a lot of
these movies and you know do something
about that
whether or not it gets attention at
least i you know i tried for something
that
i like to think that i appreciate to
some degree
i mean candace what are your thoughts
your uh uh
you know the black uh carrie
girl journalist in the big city uh
but you're also a black woman so i um
how do we
navigate how do we you know you're
writing for some of the biggest
publications
in the in the world uh so what's been
your way to sort of
keep you know obviously you're owning
completely your blackness but
not to make that the biggest issue in
the room when when it comes to story
assignments
yeah i've actually even lately i've had
to
remind editors like hey i'm not
i i i'm happy to not write about
or not write exclusively about black
movies just
especially for like editors that i'm
like newly working with
and i'm just like i don't know if i
don't know what i don't know
where they're getting this idea but i'm
just like oh let me stop before this
gets too far
and and i'm happy to and i always say i
was like i'm happy to
write about black films i love good
films no matter who makes it
but i don't want to ever i've never come
into journalism with the idea that i was
just going to write about black stories
that was never
the thing that's often put on me but
that's never been my
um that was never my uh impetus um
and so i have said that on a few
occasions to editors um
it's often i mean like sometimes it's
just like
it's just like whatever like i i feel
like especially in the last couple of
years
uh with the ascension
of the black lives matter movement i
think editors
and particularly publicists in some
regard
are feeling a lot of pressure from a lot
of different
arenas that black content should only go
to black journalists and publicists
which again publicity is largely white
and so that's a whole other thing
but um and even of black films mostly
white
uh publicist so it's it can be it can be
quite complex but yeah i've had to just
be uh
transparent um but that's definitely an
uphill
battle for sure uh but then you know
also it's sometimes the pres
preference of the the creative team
making the movie i know john singleton
you know uh went on record to say that
he
uh you know really appreciated after
because
uh he uh we represent a group of people
who
he felt would understand uniquely
understand
his movies and which is why i posed a
question to aaron you know
where does that responsibility sort of
begin and end because
maybe if um i will destroy you which is
uh
the hbo series that came on last summer
uh
you know in some ways that was a very
unique experience
you know about a you know from a black
woman and a a black woman would probably
be able to offer a greater
interpretation of of what
uh that series was supposed to was all
about
part of it's like the industry comes
from a there's a bit of a disadvantage
from the outset right as far as
who's been writing about these things
versus people like us that there's not
as many or at least not as many that are
pushed up in a certain limelight so
yeah you have to find it you know
someone like john singleton speaking to
like the opportunity like i would get
that because yeah you
there's not as much content written by
certain types of people that cover these
movies and so
if things were different and it's
everyone's just available and you
constantly had a nice balance of voices
being heard that's one thing but that's
just not the way it is right
and particularly with canvas because
she's writing for
outlets that uh make a difference
that people that really move the needle
and so when that decision
comes to whether or not we want her eyes
on this versus
someone who may not really get it
candice yeah that's definitely a thing
that's still
occurring i mean i uh
i guess like to your earlier point i
will say like when you were talking
about john singleton
which is a good example but i think that
when we talk about responsibility um
what i also kind of push back on
i'm i think that there is
another responsibility that is put on us
but i will also
add that because we because
that responsibility is placed doesn't
mean
that we are obligated to
say that this is a fantastic film which
i think that gets very
much lost repeatedly absolutely
and then you know and if you say
anything critical at all
it's like a whole thing and so
like that's that's where the that's
where like
you know when i hear responsibility i
was like yes but also just understand
that i am in no way obligated to
you know write a flattering review or
say something super positive i'm also
not
obligated to be quiet when something is
problematic and
if that even if that comes from a black
filmmaker
ideally that comes just from being
honest with yourself as a writer
and having integrity as a writer exactly
and i mean
we're at an age where yes social media
obviously pumps up a lot of things
depending on what they are and what you
know what's trending or what have
you you you just got to distance
yourself from that if you feel like
that's some kind of factor that's going
to affect
the reaction to the thing that you
decided to write because that's how you
felt
yeah i i've i felt i can't just hit a
nail on the head
um i definitely it it's sort of like a
microcosm of how
i feel about like when you go to a film
festival
and you watched a smaller movie that is
potentially angling for distribution
and you have to make the decision about
one am i if i hate this movie am i going
to review it
and then two if i hate this movie and i
am going to review it
how am i going to talk about it in a way
you know because these are
people's dreams you know and so it's the
same sort of thing with with black
cinema it's like we want the diversity
of the content we want these different
things like
the reason why it feels so high pressure
is because it's like
even with the great strides that we've
made there's just not as much content
coming out and so
if you don't like malcolm and marie and
judas and the black messiah what are you
going to do this oscar season
you know and and then it's like it
because it's like this weird
i for the record i l i like judas and
the black uh messiah
uh malcolm is a different conversation
but like
even even when i was writing that i
felt kind of emboldened by the fact that
everybody was going to be writing about
that at the same time versus them being
like hey
here's this black movie can you write
about it and being like oh my god if i
if i have to work with my integrity
and this movie is bad maybe zenday and
john david washington don't get to make
another movie so that's
it's like the external pressure is put
on you in those sort of moments and i'm
i'm fine being honest and telling people
you know how i feel about movies but it
definitely becomes like this weird
ecosystem because yes we do understand
it more
it's the reason why you can my i would
love to read
black critics takes on black things or
why i would
really like to read black women talk
about i may destroy you because like
that is a perspective
that maybe has another level of
understanding it just
shouldn't like like candice shouldn't
only write about that
only write about those types of projects
because like
she also has an understanding of other
types of projects
you know and br you you can only bring
yourself to these reviews so when
external
forces get put on you that's when it
becomes tough we're talking about a good
criticism i'm sorry i mean but it's not
what you say it's not really how you say
it
yeah exactly so you know
that's that's what i was gonna point out
the the idea of like you're you know
honing your writing crafts
is a huge part of that obviously and you
know when you talk about
movies like dude is the black with sarah
mcmurray like that you know
as a critic as any critic i mean it's
less about you saying
definitely go see this movie you're just
expressing your level of enthusiasm or a
lack thereof
and ideally your reader is going to look
at that and that includes the various
people that have
maybe made the movie that decide to read
the reviews just but
maybe many of them saying that they
don't read reviews i i think there's a
you know the aspect there should be it's
not about
whether i you know convince somebody to
go and see it
it's about like how did i convey what i
felt about this thing and
that did that convince me that i have
some kind of curiosity now or not
regardless i at least got i have no way
i have an awareness of this thing now
that i did not before from this specific
person and there's plenty of other
people
out there that can also provide that
same kind of awareness
so we're in award season oh
and i did sign when i said that
how do you guys how do each of you deal
with the demands
uh the enormous demands of of
of this uh time of year when
uh every email is important and
packages never stop coming with
all the different trinkets and whatnot
and enticements
saying hey like me like me better like
me better
so how do you find how do you how do you
what's your your trick for
for surviving award season um terence
um i
even though i i love the stuff
but getting stuff has never swayed my
vote
but please still send it if you're a
publicist or person i will i will gladly
accept it
um i've actually
like i got started at award circuit so
i'm like i remember being so
deep in it and like thinking about every
movie in the prism of the oscars
and when i left i like really pulled
back from that
because it was such a like
drain to think about it can be such a
drain to think about
movies only in respect to
what is being nominated so i sort of
have flipped that on this head and i'm
like let me just advocate
for the stuff that i really like and if
it doesn't get nominated for an oscar
that's fine i still like
the movie but really really sort of
looking at it in terms of like
advocacy uh you know because like my
favorite film in 2013 was like the
conjuring that was never going to be
nominated for an oscar
but that it's it's great yes like it's
phenomenal
so you know when i do a top 10 or i
submit you know
my ballot to the hollywood critics
association it's gonna have the stuff
on it that i like so it's really just
about
for me it's like i've had to pull back
from like the daily conversation i can't
do
who's gonna win the golden globe and
who's gone
you know and the statistics and all that
anymore i just have to be like i really
like this movie i'm happy to see it win
or it didn't get nominated but i'm
really i really like this movie
hey carla thank you for joining us
hi sorry
uh we're talking about awards season and
the additional demands that it puts on
uh our time uh
uh as uh as journalists as any
journalist
and i know that you're you're based in
la and i know that a lot of stuff is
definitely coming at you
how do you navigate that how do you
manage that
you mean the the amount of uh
titles and things that come your way
during award season right
right and the pressure to
the pressure that that uh exists uh
for you to uh i mean get behind the
project
so usually i make sure that i see
the bulk of the i can usually tell i've
been doing it long enough that i can
tell
um when i go to the film festivals you
know sundance in toronto
and tribeca and some of the other ones i
can usually tell
what is going to kind of make the cut
when award season
rolls around so i would have already
seen the film by the time the buzz
starts i would have already formed an
opinion about it by the time the buzz
starts
and so i don't feel that pressure to be
like oh my goodness i have to see this
film i have to come up
with an um an opinion about this film i
usually
by that time i've usually seen the film
about two or three times and established
a pretty
firm opinion about it and i don't allow
outside forces to
color or dictate what my opinion is my
opinion is my opinion and it's a really
strong one so
i can tell we can tell i'm pretty
i of course you can so i pretty much um
stand firm to that
what i th what i do think is a lot of
pressure
is the fact that um when
by the time it gets down to the five
nominees because you can tell
when um the critics choice awards comes
out and all the different
film critics awards around the country
when all of those start to filter in you
can kind of tell
what way it's going to go yeah
and and what i find unfortunate about
that and pressurized about that
is the fact that you know i have my
favorites
and sometimes they're not always the
ones that end up
in the race because i'm not a part of
those organizations that vote for the
final entity
a lot of the times so that's a little
frustrating from a critic standpoint
because you see
really good quality films really good
quality work
that don't make it to the cut with what
you often do see make it to the cut
or people that have a tendency to be
awards darlings
time and time again and there's nothing
wrong with that but it would be nice if
you know
something that really was of quality you
know like some small
indie film kind of just bust through and
and and paved the way like parasite did
last year
or like moonlight did a few years
earlier
right so it does happen but not
perhaps not as often as we'd like
no not in my opinion
candace what i mean i've never
experienced award season in new york uh
but what is that like
can only i bet it's i'm sure it's a lot
of fun a
pre or a post covet not you know yes
that we get more snow so there's that we
don't have i don't i feel like
because i'm not really a premiers person
i don't go to a lot of premieres and
a lot of award shows or anything like
that a lot of that happens in l.a as i'm
sure you guys are all accustomed to
i think um yes i do get the swag
um nothing and no one
has ever deterred my opinion of anything
i and like a carla my opinion is strong
and it's
for the most part i would say like yeah
like 80
of the time cannot be swayed um
and so especially when it comes to like
these like these awards conversations
which i find just
uh exhausting just because i'm i'm not
an awards pundit i
i vote for what i want to win not what i
think
is gonna win and not who i think my uh
my colleagues want to win
i could care less um
i really want what i consider to be
quality
who i consider to be quality to get
what they're do um it's often i would
say
um 50 of the time at best
is correlated with what's actually not
what's actually nominated or
actually does win awards um and 50
again that is on a good day um
and so yeah i mean i i don't feel
particularly
overwhelmed by anything i mean
because everything's like at the top of
the next year like right now
i'm not even thinking about 2020 2020 is
like so far away from me because i'm
looking ahead at like the
slew of film and tv that's forthcoming
in 2021
so i'm kind of checked out with just
like one toe
in 2020 so i don't really have that
pressure as
probably some of my colleagues do you
know what else i want to add if i may
kansas candace and i have been at film
festivals together and watched films
together and the thing that i love about
that experience that i missed um
pre-covet
is that you will come out of a movie and
walking out talking about a film
and someone will bring up a scene or a
moment in the film that can totally
change your mind about how you were
digesting that film in the moment
because i know candace and i had that
moment during a film at sundance one
time
and she said something i was like oh
right i would have never thought about
it that way
and it made me just look at it a little
differently that those conversations
i do miss not that it swayed my opinion
but it just made me look at the film in
a different light
uh aaron anything to add i mean there's
a lot of things that have been stated
that i agree with already but i
i will say that the i mean the the
benefit of award season is that hey i
get to give my dad a chance to see a lot
of things before anybody else because
it's very convenient for me to hand up
screeners and say watch this you'll
probably like it
as far as you're supposed to be the only
one
as far as having a chance to
i don't know like no like that get
getting you know various goodies or what
have you it's
that's nice i guess but it doesn't you
know it doesn't make me suddenly
like the trial chicago 7 anymore than i
already do or don't it's like it's like
okay great i have a big book now like i
don't know what else
you know you're going to try to convince
me of but you know handing me things is
going to
be the solution to that i'm very happy
to look at the films that i chose as the
best of the year as the ones i'd want to
champion for
you know the rest of it and if they
align with how things are going as far
as awards
pundits are predicting things that's
nice i guess but the fact is like i like
the things i liked
and i'm happy to you know continue
championing those things
if i had my way like if i got a food
bank from
the nomad land people i'd be happy to
donate that and if i could make
um it was good
if i could make a small accent like
count as a film again i'd be doing
everything i could to make sure that
that gets a lot more noticed than it
currently is
uh but so yeah it could be upsetting
that certain things that
have a smaller content you know fan base
or what have you don't get the attention
that
i think they deserve but at the same
time i did what i could as far as
you know mike i'm concerned to you know
throw something out there as far as my
writing goes podcast goes or what not
and uh it'd be nice to see more change
it'd be nice to be able to know that
i've convinced more to vote on something
or what have you that i
really want to champion but as far as
award season goes
am i a factor in it not a huge one uh
but you know things will go the way they
do until they start to change
okay we have a question an audience
members we encourage you to
please uh go to the q a uh section and
uh send us your questions
uh jonathan schwartz is asking as
someone who majored in african american
studies in college
and who wrote a thesis on african
americans in film
i'm considering starting my own film
blog on the subject
any advice on how to start
and anyone can take take that to answer
it
uh practically wordpress is great
um you know wordpress.com
uh to start your blog and i think i
actually think that'd be
cool you know i think that's a great
like you found something that you're
passionate about and you want to write
about
um and all you really have to do is
start writing i think that's sometimes
the bit like we
we want to do things and then we just
keep wanting to do them and wanted to do
them but i think that you have
genesis of an idea that's going to be
very specific
so like you can become an authority on
it like anybody who wants to do
african-american history can
theoretically come to you
or come to your blog and learn more
um as well as reach out to you so yeah i
just think you have to
just do it and don't don't expect to be
like the hollywood reporter level
traffic
day one if that they have had a hundred
hundred years to get to where they are
um so really just starting from the
ground just writing yeah
shaping your your prose i mean it's
important shaping your voice
finding out you know what it is that you
like to write about by writing
i think it's the you know especially if
you're starting your own you know
starting you know grassroots
starting from scratch which is you know
a lot of what i've done is just building
it from the ground up
that's that's the way to find out what
direction you want to go whether it is
writing about
very specific things like that you know
tackling a certain genre film or a
certain you know kind of filmmaker what
have you but doing that
consistency is key as well like that's
you know the more you do it the better
you'll get at it
and the more you'll think and realize
hey this is the kind of thing i want to
keep focusing on or maybe i want to you
know go to a different direction because
of how i've decided to keep writing
and what i've discovered from that yeah
it's very important to work that muscle
like anything and and uh nike's slogan
is true
uh just do it you know quit talking
about it and just
get out there and start uh
carla i think you were gonna say
something yeah i was gonna say
scheduling
apps can help you a lot when you're
starting a blog so you can take the
pressure off of yourself
of trying to figure out what you're
gonna write every day you can plan your
post
you know every week or every two weeks
whatever or bi-weekly whatever works for
you
and then you also want to find a name
for your blog
something that is indicative to your
brand and
who you have decided your voice is going
to be
as a film blogger so that people can say
oh let's catch the kirby critic today or
have you seen the kirby critics block
you know what i mean
okay find a name that is catchy that
people will remember
who you are and not make it too long so
that you can people can find you
you want people to be able to find you
for you to be able to build up the
traffic in the audience for your blog
a canvas anything you'd like to add um
i can't stress enough um finding your
voice as a writer when i was first
starting out as a journalist
after getting a degree pretty much
every editor across the board was saying
finding your voice is not which is
different from
your brand and which if it's like
african-american history that is your
brand
but your voice has to be whatever you
are it has to
because you're not going to be the only
person that's going to be writing about
african-american films
there's so much of that out there
especially now
and so it's really about what you what
are you contributing
um in terms of what how are you
enhancing the conversation and whether
that's through your academics
and and whatnot and i think also when i
look at certain uh content there is a
difference between
i can instantly tell if someone is
writing from an academic point of view
or rather than a more consumer-based
reader-based
viewership-based journalist point of
view which is
quite different um i i've never
written through an academic voice but i
think
determining how you want to
create nuance in that voice if you want
to stay within the academic space or
you know reach a larger audience
a rick has consent is an interesting
question with the pandemic ends
what do you think normal will look like
for the film industry
with mega studios now and independence
shrinking
i'm worried about the business uh
i'm worried that i'm worried that the
business will finally kill the art
thoughts nothing will ever nothing will
ever kill the art of cinema
i mean cinema will never ever go away
the way
it is consumed and the way it comes at
us may shift and change but it will
never go away
and as far as how the pandemic has
shifted the industry
junkets virtual junkets are not going
anywhere either because the studios
and um the pr companies and all those
independent
entities that spend money on those
events those premiers those red carpets
all of those things they're seeing
very very very vastly how much money
they are able to save by not doing
all of that stuff there'll be some
people that go back to that
but the majority of them i'm like i can
save a hundred thousand dollars over
here and put it over here
something else i think i'm gonna do that
over there but yeah cinema will never
cinema will never be killed the art will
never be completely null and void in my
opinion
yeah a lot of those junkets are like not
just
six figures there they approach seven
so yeah you're right we're definitely
going to see some permanent changes
yeah and i i think i definitely agree
with what carla said and i also think
in terms of like talent i feel like
talent access
will get a little easier because one of
the things that's tough with junkets
this is just from a practical like
since we're all critics and we've all
covered these types of things it's like
trying to get your foot in the door to
get an interview with somebody can be
very very hard but
with phone interviews with virtual
interviews you can cycle through those
things like
like that and the talent can be
comfortable they can be in their house
talking to you about
you know promising young women and you
don't need to be
at the four seasons the four seasons is
nice but like you know
you just don't need to be there um so
from that standpoint i think it'll it'll
be although we missed that food yeah
you know i'm worried about them what are
they gonna do all the i mean
yeah i've been having i've been real
worried about the four seasons
how they're going to make it through
it'll be different but i also think
this is going to give disabled
critics or non-able-bodied critics a
real
chance to be in the industry in the
covering this industry in a meaningful
way because like this year
we've gotten so many screener links and
so many screeners and i even though
studios will go back to
screening movies i think that now at
least
those critics who maybe can't go to a
theater
can have the access or who don't live in
la or new york
yeah yeah sorry i would say richard
curley and i think
sundance i don't have the exact numbers
right now but i know sundance released a
report something to the effect of just
like that was their largest
intended uh festival ever i think or in
the last
tk years how long years and i mean part
of that is because
journalists from everywhere in the world
was were able to attend that's on top of
the general audience who was able to
attend from everywhere
that is i mean i can imagine that's
that's that's
exponentially more people and so i think
that they're
and i'm wholeheartedly with carla like
there's i've i've never been concerned
with
the death of cinema i've never been
concerned with that i don't think that's
ever going to be a thing that's we have
survived way worse
in all of film history um and so
yeah i think this is providing access
i think films that i think when i look
back at 2020
the films that i think people
people were talking about certain films
that i don't think that they would have
originally seen
if we weren't all home with nothing else
to do
or with no access to it that's something
that
the pandemic actually helped us um
and you know that i think that's a good
thing so
i i hope it continues to go in that
direction or they'll find some other
type of algorithm to
make that benefit once the world reopens
another question is what films what
movies are you
excited about at the moment
oh that's your top two terence already
knows what i'm going to say but godzilla
versus kong is the thing that i'm
looking forward to
i mean there's there's plenty of good
stuff coming you got cairo del toro's
what nightmare alley coming pta's got a
movie coming out
uh candy man i can't look forward to but
i'm living for that
but i mean it that goes back to the
pandemic question like
i'm looking forward to seeing godzilla
versus kong at the same time
the preference wouldn't be to watch it
on my admittedly large tv like it'd be
nice to watch it
on a giant screen and so like that's
that's why i'm curious about where the
industry
goes in that regard too it's like i look
forward to seeing a massive blockbuster
i i'm curious what block courses are
going to do when they're getting the
same amount of kind of
talk time as a lot smaller things and
that goes back to that cost saving
aspect as well i was like why spend all
this money
when you're gonna watch a movie that can
be talked about and then discarded in a
week
right i'm looking forward there's two
different shirley chisholm projects
coming up one by
king and one by viola davis and i'm just
interested to know
which one is going to hit first because
it's like the battle of the shirley is
just like we got the battle of the
arethas right now and i'm kind of
excited to see those two projects too
candace oh man
i had a longer list but you just said
too and this only had to be movies and
you know i have all these tv
all these tv shows or tv shows well i
will say
uh just because it just dropped on
shutter right now and i have
uh a great interest in hora is uh the
dark and the wicked
which just dropped on the shutter i
think it is the best horror movie of
2020
and it just dropped on shutters so folks
can now watch it
another thing that i've been kind of uh
keeping an eye on for a variety of
reasons is the new york times presents
framing britney spears
and that's a very interesting
documentary in a lot of different ways
and uh what am i i mean
i'm actually in the middle of binging
jenny and georgia which just dropped on
netflix
it'll be interesting to see where that
new york times uh
series goes because they uh uh
got so much attention for the britney
project and
i'm just sort of curious to see you know
what
they're gonna do what they're gonna do
next who will be the next
subject that they'll really give a deep
dive to um
let's see we have a question here
from stephen williams if theaters do
survive the pandemic
what do they look like on the other side
also
how many hours do you spend viewing
content
ooh um
too many um and that may differ
depending on the season
award season it definitely does differ
um my roommate uh works at a movie
theater
um and one of the things that i told it
one good thing is i was like
you can never go backwards with your
cleaning standards
so we at least have that to look forward
to
the cleaning standards can't go
backwards post a pandemic
um i think i think you're
going to start to really
i think you go one of two ways it's
either you're gonna see a lot more
emphasis put on the blockbusters
and the mid-range movies will continue
to go to streaming because these people
have streaming services that they need
to fill out
or movie theaters are going to be so
starved to get you back that
everything is going to play there like
they are not going to care
about if it's just the blockbuster
because they need the indie audience
they don't just want the indie audience
sitting at home watching movies on hbo
max they want
people to come to the theaters because
they need you to buy the popcorn and the
hot dog and the sodas and all that so
it's
i'm going to look at a glass half full
and think they're going to be like
anything that wants to play in a theater
that they can show
depending on the type of theater chain
that they are that they're going to want
to do
but you know i'm sure there are a lot of
uh filmmakers who
are uh um
content with not having to uh deal with
the burden of the box office right now
yeah i actually think that's that's
something that's really helped out like
minority filmmakers like you don't have
to say names but we know the ones
yeah it's because i've there have been a
couple of directors in the past year
that i have been very very angry at
their insistence that everybody go to
the movies
while you know 500 000 people are dying
in this country
um but like i do think it's an
interesting place to come in if you're
like a younger filmmaker if you're
making your first movie
and streaming is an option because now
you don't have to worry about like
oh my film didn't make you know a
certain amount per screen
like that that pressure can be taken off
of you
but the audience will still get your
content
you know like think about like avaday
talking about
how people in selma couldn't see selma
because there was no movie theater there
you know but maybe if that movie were
made today
you know it get a release like judas and
the black messiah and then they could
have
seen it in the city so yeah i think
there's going to be lots of it's like a
democratization of it it's not just
going to be all theater change but i do
think they're going to want to
lure everybody back with a ton of movies
uh any other thoughts on that will movie
theaters survive
i think that um i think
i think the movie theaters like the ipix
the ones
that that before the pandemic had that
specialized
kind of movie going experience where it
was like 20 seats in a theater
i think those will probably do better
than the big huge
theaters because in the big huge
theaters they're gonna have to like
resection those theaters
it's not gonna you who wants to go and
sit back up under somebody
in the theater now after we've lost over
you know 500 000 people you know one of
my relatives being one of them so it's
like
i don't necessarily want to have that
experience i think what's going to
happen is
the studio films may go back into
theaters but i think the indie films
and the smaller films are going to stay
in the streaming room because more
people can see the films that way
as opposed to trying to see them in the
art house because not all cities
have art house theaters for people to
see those types of films
so for them to stream makes it a little
bit more universal for people to see it
in their own homes you know what i'm
saying
i i'm very curious what that means as
far as the behind the scenes as do we
talk about the box office or what have
you but yeah
having the means to stream things does
that mean there's gonna be more
opportunities for smaller filmmakers to
make things now
or is it gonna be we're like we're right
in the middle of
history so it's like it's hard to i have
that determination
but um i'm still you know very curious
about it
candace uh
no i mean i i i don't have anything for
you
this is a city like new york where
that's a whole thing
dinner and a movie and yeah that's why
i'm just like
i i just don't see people not going i
think the
the experience will be different but i
don't think the venue will be different
i think there will be i mean i know from
myself i have my own sensibilities that
i
i probably won't be rushing to see it i
also have access that other people don't
so i don't have the urgency to do that
um but uh uh yeah i also i mean like
because i go yes i go to the movies
professionally but i also go just like
you know with friends and family and
oftentimes after i've already seen
something and i'm watching it new with
them i
i i'll probably still do that um
but it would be a far more cautious
situation
um and it would be one once i'm ready to
do something like that once they're
ready to do that but
yeah i don't think that the movie
theaters
um would go away um i do think they're
struggling right now for sure
and there's so many there's so many
options to go to movies here in new york
because there's art house and there's
blockbuster and there's like
international theaters there's it's
everywhere and so
that's kind of our thing um yeah like
you said dinner in a movie
a good this is a real good question do
you ever worry about any of you ever
worry about
uh being able to say something not being
able to say something new
i know when i worked at a trade um
many many many years ago it was sort of
like grinding you
had to do three this three review three
album reviews three single reviews three
so when it gets to that kind of thing
you find those moments where
i was just telling a friend of mine
sometimes the muse is just simply
not in the room and she won't come in
the room
because she's she wants to be difficult
and
despite all of your enticements she just
won't arrive
so i mean have any of you experienced
that i mean
other other also known as writer's block
a writer's block oh yeah well saying
something new you're trying to think of
that real cool
saying something okay i miss her you
know i think yeah i heard that
differently
okay yeah writer's block that's
something especially since
especially if you're writing continually
um and sometimes i'm just like
a lot of sometimes i i have a lot of
stories that are pre-written in my head
and once i get them on the paper i'm
just like i have that when i call it a
very judgmental blank white page
just like splashing at me and i'm just
like i don't i don't have the words
they're all stuck in here
jumbled uh but i have the thought um
but yeah that's um a lot of times i
especially now in the pandemic i have to
like walk around my apartment several
times and like
i don't know sometimes i watch things
sometimes i read things which i can't
stress enough is such a critical part of
being a writer is also being a reader
um and so that's nice i mean what are
some of your triggers do you
walk through the park coffee going to
the well i guess you're not going out
for coffee now but
what are some of the things that that
you know
definitely reading um sometimes having a
conversation with somebody
i'm just like oh that's interesting i
you know i was telling this to somebody
the other day a lot of my story ideas
come from like conversations with people
i'm just like oh that would make a good
story or like a question that somebody
asked that i wasn't able to
answer um and so that's those are kind
of a lot of my inspirations
is just from like getting out of my own
head as i call it i need it
right like talk talk it out with other
people
what about you oh i'm sorry go ahead
we'll come back to you next
i i think as far as finding something
new to say
like creating something like that comes
from like
you know having a certain kind of
passion where i think for me it's
especially difficult when i like want to
write a review for a movie i absolutely
like loved like i give like you know
five stars whatever too because it's
like how do you
how do you you know put out their
passion and enthusiasm in a way that's
more than just i like this and this and
this and this there's obviously you know
there's ways to do that
we do this so you know we'll solve that
problem but when it comes to saying
something new
sometimes that just like i it weirdly
like applies to like movies i know are
not going to get much attention or
traction and it's like but i really put
a lot of effort in they're like writing
about this one thing
or it could be just something that it
just has that kind of x factor where you
just
you feel like you need to you know say
more than the average kind of thing like
something like small acts for example i
was very passionate about that i thought
it was my
the the entire body of that work was my
number one film for last year
and i was very happy to like have the
chance to see them in advance and write
about each individual
movie separately and am i finding
something new to say
for me it felt like i was you know
playing around with
what i want to say about certain kinds
of things beyond just describing what it
is and why i liked it i wanted to get
into like what steve mcqueen's trying to
accomplish with those films
um do those opportunities come all the
time to say something new
for me because i write mainly reviews i
don't so much write editorials too often
like in my in my way i know what i'm
accomplishing i feel like on a weekly
basis
and i'm generally very satisfied with
that i don't feel like i'm
you know rehashing the same old thoughts
again and just applying it to different
movies so
do i get blocked not so much like it's
you know something yeah like you know
take a walk take a breath do what you
need to do to like refresh yourself
but you know i i work through it i guess
you have to carla
i don't get writer's block as much as i
get writer's burnout
because sometimes the projects come at
you so fast and furious
that you have like four five six seven
pieces that have to come out
like all on the same day or within a
couple of days
and that kind of is annoying and i just
kind of take my time and go you know
what
i work for myself i don't have a
deadline it'll get out when i get out
that's the first thing and the second
thing is um
most of my stuff is usually generated i
usually skew the stories around
something that i resonated with watching
it something in my life that i resonated
with
that i can start the store start the
review off with to get it
to give it some kind of track give it
some kind of focus
so that it's not all over the place love
that
yeah something to that i
i find that it's not necessarily
sometimes i do struggle with
the pressure to say something new and
then i'm like
i'm just writing about a movie and then
i have to like give myself some grace
and i i actually kind of find comfort in
going back to like a templatized way of
thinking about something
because when you're really struggling
it's like maybe that review
is not meant to be the lovely personal
essay with like one line
about the movie maybe that review is
meant to be introduction
plot things you like things you hated
conclusion
that's a good device too yeah yeah you
just have to like
go with it yeah because the movies the
movies that are actually really hard to
write about other movies where you
don't feel anything one way or the other
um and that's where i tend to go to that
like templatized function because it's
like
if i really hate a movie there's lots of
things i can talk about if i really love
a movie there's lots of things i talk
about but if it's in that middle
then i'm like all right back to back to
the template
and just get to the end and hit publish
it's interesting you say like i i mean
we're all different obviously but like
when i see a movie that i have nothing i
you know i'm not passionate about it or
what have you
that's to me works as like a challenge
like okay i have to write about this
thing that i'm
fairly indifferent towards how do i make
that interesting how do i make that
interesting for myself as a writer and
to as a reader as far as
you know this movie that you know i
don't feel either way about or just it's
an average film
i like the idea of sitting down and
being like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna make
this
i may be indifferent about this movie
i'm going to make it the most
interesting review i can
based off my own interest in how to do
that like that that's me i
it's just one way to look at it at this
point sometimes you just don't have the
time
you don't have the time on the bandwidth
to put that
extra into it because you've got to get
to the next piece
oh as candace put very well rinse do on
the first
right is do it it comes fast and furious
every month
i can't spend a lot of time i can't
spend a lot of time with you baby
papa gotta eat that's right
that is right uh you guys have been
absolutely wonderful
uh thank you uh two of you carla
candace are our members of of my
organization the african-american
film critics association and terence and
aaron we uh
would love to see both of you in our
ranks as well
so uh film independent it's been
wonderful we appreciate
uh sharing this platform with you uh
and here's paul thank you gil
uh this has been terrific uh i know you
have so much to say and
we could keep going but we are out of
time i just wanted to do
a quick thank you around the table here
and ask everyone where
um our viewers can follow you candice
where's the best place to follow you on
what socials where
what's your handle are you muted right
now
oh i was talking too um so twitter at
real talker r-e-e-l-t-a-l-k-e-r
is where to find me and uh a lot of my
work
great terence uh you can find me on
twitter
and instagram at terence b johnson
that's terence with
one r and no a
no no are you sure yeah you know uh john
every black person in america's name
johnson that's
is that that's how we find you terrence
b johnson yeah it's just my it's my
first name middle initial last name got
it got it
you want to mention your website as well
uh yeah and i write a little tour.net
l-e-n-o-i-r-a-u-t-e-u-r dotnet
great uh aaron find me on twitter
aaron's ps4 my personal blog is
thecodazzeeq.com everything i do ends up
over there but i write for weekly
entertainment
and why so blue and i host the podcast
out now with aaron and abe which is
available everywhere you can find
podcasts
and uh carla great that you could join
us i know you said you're on set
but you are of course the curvy critic
some of uh film independent members
would recognize you
um so we're gonna they would
yeah you guys can find me across all
social media platforms
at the kirby c-u-r-v-y critic
my website is thecurvyfilmcritic.com and
you can catch my
uh podcast on youtube every sunday
specific time at five o'clock the kirby
critic with carl renata
what and carla can you take a picture
can i take a picture
can't you do it with your your computer
no i thought you were on an apple where
you could just take it or do a screen
i am but i don't know how to do that oh
i'm sorry
if you tell me how to do it i can do it
no no no i'll just get a quick snap
okay i can i can do it too for you girl
as well
a good paula do it uh oh paul do it okay
he just did it oh you okay thank you
and finally gill um
afka has a website right after has a
website
uh aafca.com on twitter where
the africa t-h-e-a-a-f-c-a
dot com aaron thanks for the follow saw
that we're following you back
and on instagram we're at aafca
and on facebook african-american film
critics association
and on youtube the afka channel
right and thank you so much for
moderating today
it's been terrific thank you this has
been a lot of fun
yes this was great this has been a
coffee talk with film independent if
you're not a member of film independent
you can check out
filmindependent.org membership is open
to everyone filmmakers and film lovers
we will see you very soon back here for
coffee talks but
uh until then i want to thank our great
panel
candice terence aaron carla and gil
thank you everyone